[Music]
when you come into Lima hooli you're
gonna see plants that you've seen
nowhere else in the world all of this
diversity is a foundation that Hawaiian
culture was built on I hear the voices
of the old Hawaiians talking about how
special this place is and pushing me to
really care for this place
[Music]
the moldy garden preserve is a one
thousand acre botanical garden and
nature preserve situated on the north
shore on the island of Kauai in the
Hawaiian Islands my job is to basically
garner support for our protection of
this place and the restoration of this
value
[Music]
some of the plants that we have now
they're so rare that you have to go on a
four-mile hike deep into the valley or
risk your life and climb one of those
Peaks to get to them
[Music]
one of the examples of that is this
plant called Ola na which is the second
strongest fibre in the world now that
plant is pretty rare and the only exists
way deep back in the wet values of the
Highland within the context of the
Hawaiian culture every plant has a name
when a plant goes extinct that's a part
of our language it dies it's our job to
make sure that they they stick around
for future generation
[Music]
so this tree right here this is a really
important tree culturally it's a
hardwood it's the second hardest wood in
the forest its name is GU Hugh key it's
down to two trees left on the island a
kawaii so this is one tree that you're
not gonna really find anywhere else
200 years ago all these plants were all
around the community was actively
cultivating them but there's been a huge
disconnect in the past 200 years between
the community and the resources of the
valley this is actually the state flower
unfortunately our state flower is down
to just a handful of individuals in the
wild so it's kind of a pretty strong
statement of the state of affairs of our
native plants I can feel the rare plants
calling for help we talk about
sustainability nowadays we don't have to
reinvent the wheel the ancient hawaiians
did it they were doing it for a
millennium at least in Hawaiian culture
we just try to be at a point where
you've given more than you've taken that
resource management system is viable in
the 21st century to address a lot of the
problems we're dealing with nowadays
[Music]
if we're engaging with the ocean we
don't just go down there and fish we
build few choices so that there's more
habitat for the fish to live in and on
the forest you go and take care of the
place make sure that the plants are
healthy before you gather and then
before you leave you replant behind you
so there's more for tomorrow you take
responsibility for something and then
you have a right to access it
humanity doesn't have to be separated
for nature and there are ways for
humanity to engage nature such that both
benefit this place can be a model it can
be a model of how humanity is connected
to nature and that is probably the most
important story in Hawaiian culture
[Music]